bonsoir
alors agnès de marnach bastien thiry
vous êtes
psychogénéalogiste thérapeute mais
surtout filles du lieutenant colonel
bastien thiry fusillé le 11 mars 1963 au
fort d'ivry
d'ailleurs été la dernière personne
fusillé en france fusillé pour avoir
tenté d'assassiner le général de gaulle
au petit clamart six mois plus tôt alors
pendant trente ans vous avez oublié ce
père vous aviez trois ans quand il a été
fusillé on en parlait pas beaucoup chez
vous avec votre mère et et vos soeurs et
puis à l'âge de 40 ans vous ressentez
une véritable souffrance et vous décidez
de retrouver ce père cette enquête
cette quête on pourrait dire vous n'avez
fait un livre qui paraît chez michalon
et qui s'appelle mon père le dernier des
fusils et voilà alors les seuls
souvenirs que vous ayez de votre père
agnès c'est qu'on vous alliez le voir au
parloir vous avez 3 62 ans et demi trois
cents oui quels souvenirs vous gardez de
lui je me souviens donc je tenais la
main de ma mère et on attendait pendant
des heures devant la porte de la prison
de la santé et puis enfin on ne pouvait
rentrer il y avait tout un tout un
pèlerinage à faire avant de rentrer
sains dans le parloir où mon père nous
attendait derrière la vitre
ses biens et de ses théories parce que
j'étais donc une petite fille de deux
ans et demi trois ans quand j'arrivais
dans ce par loire c'était la fête parce
que c'était le seul moment où je
retrouvais mon père et et le voir
j'avais envie qu'il me prenne dans ses
bras je riais jeu taper du pied aux
fesses j'étais une petite fille très
très heureuse de voir et je me
précipitais vers lui et il y avait cette
vitre qui nous séparait désespérément
alors ce qui est plus incroyable dans
cette histoire c'est comment un homme
comme votre père c'est-à-dire
polytechnicien issu d'une famille de
militaires a pu en arriver là pourquoi
est ce que votre père a décidé plusieurs
fois parce qu'avant le petit clamart il
y avait eu la tentative de
pont-sur-seine pourquoi at il décidé
d'assassiner le général de gaulle oui
c'est très étonnant de savoir comme
qu'un homme polytechnicien qui était un
inventeur de missiles très sophistiqué
ss 10 11 qui a été décoré de la légion
d'honneur qui était marié père de trois
enfants qui avaient une carrière
éblouissante et qui aurait pu terminer
générale solide et bien il a fait ce
choix parce que il s'est révolté contre
l'abandon du peuple algérien et c'est
quelque chose qui la fait terriblement
souffrir
il a été décidé d'agir il a décidé de
prendre position et de faire quelque
chose c'est l'abandon d'après lui c'est
l'abandon de l'algérie par la france le
sort réservé aux pieds-noirs le sort
réservé aux harkis c'est ça la révolte
et il a décidé d'abattre le responsable
pour lui de sa le général de gaulle pour
lui le seul responsable c'était donc le
général de gaulle qui avait trahi sa
parole et lui en tant que militaire il a
pas il n'a pas supporté la pas tolérer
qu'un militaires comme le général de
gaulle trahissent et ne respecte pas sa
parole
alors effectivement votre terre était
chrétien donc on comprend mal qu'il ait
voulu assassiner quelqu'un d'ailleurs
vous dites dans votre livre c'est un des
points que que vous soulevez vous dites
qu'en fait il était opposé à
l'assassinât du général de gaulle que
lui voulait seulement l'enlever ils
voulaient l'enlever pour le juger ce cas
c'est que il des membres du cener le
bruit des pas dans l'ouest faut dire
qu'ils perdront famille cnr le comité
national de la résistance qui avait été
créée par jacques soustelle et georges
bidault qui était d'aider grand
gaulliste pendant la guerre et donc il y
avait une espèce de légitimité disons
ouais donc il a jamais fait partie de l'
os et là il ya une confusion très
souvent on l'associent à l'os et basse
caterina jamais jamais fait partie de
l'ouest il faisait partie donc ce qu'on
de ce conseil national de la résistance
ils avaient reçu l'ordre de
d'abattre le général de gaulle 1 et lui
en tant que militaire il a il a essayé
d'obéir aux ordres mais il ya eu quand
même six tentatives d'attentât et
à montrer à son procès mon père a dit
emma c'est bien la preuve que je n'ai
pas voulu tuer de gaulle
et moi je pense que au moment de
l'attentât du petit clamart
quand il a vu la voiture présidentielle
arrivé il ya eu cette sorte de dualité
en lui à la fois le côté militaire
qui a le sens de la parole donnée qui
doit obéir aux ordres et d'un autre côté
cet homme profondément chrétien avec des
fortes valeurs morales il est et qu'il y
avait un sens très profonde du respect
de la vie humaine et je pense que là ce
moment précis ça s'est joué à quelques
secondes près il n'a pas pu et il a
suffi de quelques secondes pour que le
signal ne soit pas donnée c'est lui qui
devait donner un signal vous dites le
jour de l'attentât les tireurs
effectivement ce que vous dites avec
comme concis oui de crever les pneus de
la voiture et façon à enlever le général
de gaulle y est adjugé effectivement et
evs atteint 10 la boiteuse qui est un
des maillons du commando désobéi et là
je suis une fall à la hauteur des de la
tête des passagers de la ds19 occupé par
le général de gaulle hier donc il a été
ratée le goal de très peu et il a dit
après ces gens-là tirs comme des cochons
et batin dit j'ai désobéi aux ordres en
tire un plus haut justement il a désobéi
aux ordres du chef alors quand quand
votre père était arrêté il se justifie
en disant que c'est pour servir
l'intérêt national et finalement pour
justifier son acte il dit que c'est un
petit peu comme l'attentât contre hitler
en 44
oui bon il a il a fait cette comparaison
je crois qu'il en a parlé également à
son procès en tant que en tant que
catholique y disait que
l'église catholique a demandé
tyrannicide dire que quelqu'un devient
un tyran il est du devoir des
catholiques de le tuer donc c'est dire
que quelque part il reconnaissait quand
même que y'avait un attentat qui se
préparait un attentat meurtrier ah oui
tout à fait et encore une fois je suis
sûr qu'ils avaient reçu des ordres et
les ordres qu'il avait reçu du cener
c'était sa mission c'était d'abattre le
général du nord mais bon alors au procès
ce qui est extraordinaire c'est que
votre père est plus intéressé par l'idée
de faire passer sa vérité à lui son
message plutôt que d'assurer sa défense
il a été très très léger dans sa défense
mais cherchez pas du tout à se défendre
et et c'est vrai que dès le début du
procès les avocats ont dit que les
cartes étaient déjà joué à l'avancé
et mon père n'a rien fait pour pour se
défendre et d'ailleurs à un moment en il
s'est moqué du général de gaulle en
disant quand on lui a demandé qu'est ce
que vous auriez fait si le général de
gaulle s'était débattue au moment où on
arrêtait il a dit on lui aurait enlevé
ses lunettes et ses bretelles et toute
la salle et toute la france a ri et à ce
moment là un avocat a dit il a signé sa
peine de mort connaissant de gaulle oui
alors il a été condamné à mort il ces
trois condamnés à mort et deux autres
ont été graciés et lui a été fusillé
mais tout est bon ça n'est peut-être pas
ce que deux vols étaient profondément
humilié par set dans cette réflexion et
bien été fusillé devant une cour
militaire une cour d'exception il a fait
une cour qui a jugé sans appel et
bon il faut pas il faut pas l'oublier ça
il a été jugé devant une cour de
juridiction d'exception l excellent a
refusé qu'on lui bande les yeux oui oui
au moment où le peloton a tiré sur lui
il a refusé d'avoir les yeux bandés et
la regarder les hommes qui tirait sur
lui droit dans les yeux
voilà la dernière fois que vous avez
votre père c'est palais de justice un
bleu au palais de justice c'était début
mars était avec mes soeurs et ma mère
est en fait j'étais pratiquement la
seule à pouvoir aller voir mon père en
prison parce que mes soeurs avaient donc
à l'époque 7 et 6 ans et elle pouvait
comprendre moi comme j'avais deux ans et
demi trois ans bon le fait pas on m'a
emmené en prison je ne vais pas de
questions mais sort aurait pu poser des
questions et à l'époque on leur a fait
croire que il était dans un jeu d'enfant
et puis dans un hôpital militaire
et donc le juge raynaud a accepté qu'il
voie une dernière fois ses enfants et
donc il nous a reçus dans son bureau où
mon père se trouvait sans menottes sans
garde et à ce moment là ça a été un
grand bonheur ça a été notre dernière le
plus la vitre il n'y avait plus la vitre
il nous a pris dans ses bras les unes
après les autres il nous a serré et ça a
été un moment
exceptionnel mais soeur s'en souviennent
moi non parce que je pense que une scène
aussi traumatisante vous l'avez face et
je pense que je les fasse un jeu les
lieux cultes et est donc ça a été très
bref comme scène mais très intense et
après nous a dit au revoir et
et je sais que en retournant dans sa
cellule il pleurait il pleurait parce
que c'est la dernière fois qu'ils
voyaient ses enfants dans votre mère a
dit papa est mort pour la france ce qui
fait que vous avez été élevé là non dans
cette espèce de rythme de culte voilà ce
qui est terrible c'est le côté hassan ii
du général de gaulle c'est à dire que il
a tout fait pour que votre mère n'est
pas de pension à quelques semaines près
elle doit avoir une pension dont ce qui
fait que non seulement votre père a été
fusillé et qu'en plus votre famille a
été réduite à la misère et si votre mère
a pu acheter sa maison de bourg la reine
c'est grâce aux dons qui sont arrivées
de lin de gens qui partageaient les
idées de votre père exactement oui jo
annoncé ma mère s'est trouvée sans
ressources elle a dû rembourser les
frais du procès
et elle a eu droit à aucune pension et
c'est vrai que les droits de pension se
sont joués à 15 jours alors que les
heures de vol de mon père aurait dû
compter oui bien sûr donc il ya eu
vraiment une fatalité qui est tombé sur
nous certains hommes de notre famille
ont eu leur carrière brisée nous ça a
été terrible pour pour mes soeurs et moi
surtout mes soeurs aînés qui ont dû
changer d'école un cours d'année
inscrits sous un pseudonyme
ça a été mais il faut vraiment celle de
l'assassin oui on dit djilla la tête de
l'assassin la fille de basque a tiré les
leçons du est inscrite jeudi sous un
pseudonyme parce que pour éviter les
réflexions des petites amies alors de
gaulle en plus le respectez votre père
il disait c'est le plus intelligent de
tous parce qu'il le comparer aux
généraux du putsch qui jouait au ballon
dans la cour de la prison de tulle en
disant il n'est pas comme ces connards
qui joue au ballon à tulle il le
respecter et et en fait quand je lui ai
demandé pourquoi il avait fait fusiller
disait eh ben les français ont besoin de
martyrs ça fera un martyr quoi donc l
espèce aussi de cynisme de la raison
d'état aujourd'hui vous avez honte
vous êtes fiers de votre père je suis
très fier de mon père et tout ce travail
que j'ai fait qui a duré quatre ans j'ai
mis quatre ans à écrire ce livre ça ça
m'a permis d'avoir un nouveau regard sur
sur ce père que je connaissais si peu en
fait pendant toute ma jeunesse et toute
mon adolescence j'ai un peut rejeter
l'existence de ce père je connaissais
très peu je savais pratiquement rien sur
lui j'avais jamais rien lu comme comme
livres etc autour de la quarantaine que
j'ai décidé vraiment d'aller à la
découverte pourquoi vous êtes fier de
lui parce que ce qu'il a fait c'est
courageux certes enfin c'était au nom
d'une idéologie
obsolète dire que l'algérie ne pouvait
pas rester française l'algérie ne
pouvait pas rester des départements
français il fallait que l'algérie soit
algérienne donc ça voilà ça c'est
indéniable donc c'est hier de quoi
aujourd'hui je suis fier de mon père un
peu comme s'il avait réussi soyez aussi
fier oui oui parce que d'abord c'est mon
père et puis je ne suis pas là pour
juger je suis pas là pour le condamner
je suis là pour le comprendre et mon
livre c'est ça l'objectif de mon livre
c'est cette quête que j'ai mené ce
puzzle que j'ai essayé de reconstituer
pour aller pour essayer de comprendre
l'allemand justement un homme de cette
valeur qu'on appelait le jeune von braun
français oui c'est vrai et les
américains voulaient de lui et il est
disait que quand bastien thiry aurait
terminé sa peine il lui donnerait tous
les moyens pour pour et en même temps il
a brillé sur des promotions il a flingué
une carrière qui aurait pu être
exceptionnel vous pensez quoi du général
de gaulle agnès pas le général de gaulle
il est ce qu'il est il a fait des
grandes choses mais la sphère basque a
tiré quand même reste une tâche est bon
il faut pas l'oublier ça attendez il ya
quand même tiré sur lui quelqu'un qui
essaie de vous êtes fasciné c'est normal
pas me tromper on se défend non mais oui
mais oui il est obligé de rendre la loi
du talion ils pouvaient le gracier et
c'est vrai que quand m richard dupuis
est allé demander la grâce de bastien
thiry il lui a dit mais vous pouvez pas
faire une veuve de plus et trois
orphelines dans cette guerre d'algérie
est votre religion vous le défenseur et
il s'est adressé aux militaires parce
que un autre avocat de la défense disait
c'est une affaire entre militaires
d'homme à homme mais
rien n'y a fait rien ni à volonté
inflexible inflexible inflexible décote
bon quand on compare le pape qui est
allé embrasser
à la hauteur en prison bon
il n'a pas gracié et il a fait trois
orphelines et une veuve
retient il en aura été très créée par
jean
vous êtes sûr qu'il voulait seulement
l'enlever et pas l'assassiner moi je ne
peux pas répondre à sa place je veux pas
me mettre dans la peau de bastien thiry
mais moi je pense que un homme de cette
valeur un homme profondément chrétien
avec des convictions morales n'a pas pu
n'a pas pu tirer sur un homme sur du be
men pour le savoir agnès on va
accueillir maintenant quelqu'un qui a
participé à l'attentât du petit clamart
qui était avec votre père à cette époque
là c'est lie aux smartphones
bonsoir bonsoir bienvenue bonsoir
monsieur alors lajos maarten est publié
aux rochers en 2002 un livre qui
s'appelle il faut tuer de gaulle pour
vous l'intention de l'attentât du
petit-clamart c'était bien de tuer de
wolski pas de l'enlever oui vous êtes
sûr de ça fait après mieux oui vous dit
que j'aille heures finalement le fait
que au premier attentat a ponte 16 c'est
une bombe oui ça on ne met pas des
bombes pour enlever les gens dorment à
des bombes donc ça c'est une chose oui
le mais il faut voir ce qu avait dans la
bombe d'ailleurs ça n'a pas marché et
confiée à la difficile non c'était très
mauvaise qualité et quand on pense que
mon père quand même dirigé des projets
très sophistiquée des missiles bon cette
bombe et belvisi le décrit dans son
livre c'est est ce que vous dites c'est
qu'en fait la bombe du premier attentat
de prendre sur cette était en fait une
bombe qui n'était pas destinée à tuer
c'est ce que vous dites ce que je veux
dire c'est que mon père voulait sa
tribune pour être entendu du peuple
français voilà donc en effet les ordre
était donné l'ordre était donné de tuer
le général de gaulle mais lui il a tout
fait quelque part pour ne pas le gracier
pourquoi parce que ils voulaient sa
tribune il voulait se voulait pour être
entendus et de retenir et pouvoir parler
comment parler d'avoir le talent vous
êtes d'accord avec ça non
malheureusement
cher et agnès 1 jeudi ce que j'ai vu ce
que j'ai vécu est lorsqu on nous avait
donné vous dites d'ailleurs lajos que
quand vous allez rencontrer bastien
thiry entre l'attentât du petit clamart
et le moment où lui-même a été arrêté
oui est ce qu a pris un peu de temps oui
vous dites que il vous parlait encore de
tuer le général de gaulle il a dit voilà
il a posé la question à tous ceux toutes
les personnes du commando qu'il pouvait
voir d'après vous pourquoi on a raté
alors je les ai nommé ray les raisons
visibilité n'était pas extra et puis une
pluie fine commencé à tomber donc il
était là c'est lui qui donnait l'ordre
de tirer en ouvrant le journal
évidemment aujourd'hui ça passerait
autrement avec les efforts de mobil 1 et
c'est bernier qui était notre chef de
voiture une estafette qui était le plus
puissamment armés de fusils mitrailleurs
type 24-29 qui fonctionnait très bien
nous on avait des pistolets mitrailleurs
moi j'avais un pistolet mais thompson
les bras vous n'êtes pas arrivé à le
tuer alors donne son accord oui
en fait votre coeur belle et même moment
des vitesses un moment
ce que vous dites c'est que quand on dit
que bastien thiry voulait simplement
enlever le général de gaulle c'est en
fait à quelque chose qui était inventée
par la défense au procès c'était un
système de défense des avocats je vous
donne ma parole que je n'ai jamais
entendu au premier briefing c'était au
mois de mars 62 ou max alias de la
tocnaye lieutenant qui était notre chef
il y avait une grande table avec des
petites voitures est déjà content il
nous a annoncé l'opéra sur charlotte
corday quelqu'un qui connaît l'histoire
de france chalon nature et mallet pour
sa baignoire donc vous ce que vous dites
c'est que l'enlèvement c'est une idée
qui a été inventé c'est la défense des
avocats les avocats vous dites que si
agnès dit ça aujourd'hui c'est peut-être
c'est ce que tu as fait un sol en elle a
envie d'avoir son père mais ils n'ont
pas comme un assassin mais comme
quelqu'un qui voulait simplement général
de gaulle et vous dit même que bastien
thiry disait à ses avocats moi je veux
pas mentir je vois la vérité il a dit je
ne vais pas accepter parce que ce serait
une lâcheté de ma part et les avocats
insistent et vous connaissez la
mentalité des avocats s'il veut sauver
par tous les moyens leurs clients c'est
leur boulot ouais
voilà alors défendre et quand que les
avocats un des avocats peut-être richard
dupuis 20 qui lui avait dit ne fais pas
pour vous mais faites pour votre
commando donc vous vous dites que de
gaulle devait être abattu par deux
étaient tous et oui les pattes histoire
d'enlèvement absolument pas vous vous
êtes hongrois oui j'avais beaucoup
souffert évidemment votre vie du
communisme vous avez participé en 1956
au soulèvement de la population
hongroise en particulier à budapest où
il est réfugié en france et alors vous
êtes mêlé à cette histoire de tuer de
gaulle parce qu'en fait pas du tout pour
l'algérie vous vous sais pas ce que vous
pensez que de gaulle était un allié du
communisme était un allié de moscou je
ne pense pas un monsieur ali son jeu
suite des faits historiques vous dites
que pendant la guerre de gaulle a été en
contact avec un général russe et qu' il
a déclaré qu'il
était à ingolstadt dans un camp de
prisonniers où il était avec le futur
marche à toi qu'est ce qui d'ailleurs de
voile a fait pas mal de déclarations
mais je voudrais citer un fait
historique de gaulle est allé en
novembre décembre 44
moscou - pour faire je récite la belle
et bonne alliance avec staline c'était
la seule façon de se débarrasser des
nazis même monsieur allison soit soyons
normalement renseigner en
1944 l'allemagne s'est battu
architecture alors de gaulle qu'il
puisse dire au mois de décembre 44 que
c'est avec staline c'est à dire la forme
le plus abominable le plus criminel du
communisme la belle et bonne alliance
alors on dit mme arthaud était intoxiqué
par ce qu'il pensait on lui a dit
j'attendais pas qu'on me dise quoi que
ce soit alors ce que vous révéler dans
votre livre qui est très intéressant
c'est qu'en fait j'avais une tourbe de
l'eau est oui dans l'entourage du
général de gaulle jacques contre l'autre
qui était contrôleur général de la
police qui était au courant de tous les
déplacements du général de gaulle donc
évidemment c'était ça permettait de
toutes ses tentatives
oui d'attentats c'est une révélation que
vous faites alors pourquoi est ce que de
gaulle a toujours été ratée dans ces
attentats quand même parce que j'ai eu
un paquet
de jolies paires que c'était un miracle
parce que vos petits comment nous avons
tiré à 250
koutchma dont 150 il ya une
demi-douzaine de d'impact dans la
voiture de de gaulle
donc
ça m'ira alors
c'est leur art de la guerre si vous
voulez vous avez été condamné à mort par
contumace
oui il ya ensuite il est revenu il a été
jugé il a été condamné à 20 ans revient
sur ses 20 ans vous avez fait combien 4
ans 6 mois et 12 jours qui vous a gracié
de bol
mais peut-être pourquoi tu dois savoir
renault ne pas avoir à 6 heures non non
devant il n'y avait pas choix que de
vous n'avez jamais dans sa vie parce que
la façon dont nous comme disait agnès il
était mesquin il était imbu de sa
personnalité sais c'est pas comme
attendu il va alors voilà aujourd'hui
vous regrettez d'avoir participé à
l'attentât du petit-clamart ou non non
je suis fier de ma vie était pas avait à
ma disposition à la disposition des
officiers français qu'ils me considèrent
comme le flair l'épinard aussi imaginons
si de gaulle avaient été tués ce jour là
aussi il a marqué ce qui se serait passé
y aurait eu qui à la tête de la france
d'après mes renseignements on aurait
constitué un gouvernement de salut
public train avec les généraux et ça
aurait évité par le massacre moi je dis
c'était une une abomination c'était une
nettoyage ethnique avant l'heure un
million même plus d'un million de
clients noirs qui est muté au nord
c'était inadmissible c'est désolant
c'est la guerre par contre les allemands
il a fait la guerre contre d'autres ce
qu'on sait
bien
ben voila je crois qu'on a fait le tour
du problème merci agnès merci d'avoir
été avec nous merci l'alliance
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de in
a l'habitude abonnez vous il m'était
impossible eux